[Music]
so when I reviewed the Disney Channel
Original Movies a lot of people were
saying you forgot the Phantom of the
megaplex how could you forget Phantom of
the megaplex I was trying to think if I
even remember the title for some reason
I was thinking it wasn't are you afraid
of the dark episode after finally
sitting down and watching the movie I
can kind of see why this film is
definitely targeted at little kids
everything is over-the-top everything is
overacted everything is super goofy
there's virtually nothing in it for
adults but I'll limit if I was a little
kid I think I would probably like this
the film centers around the megaplex and
the colorful characters that work there
as it turns out there's gonna be a big
movie premiere that everybody has to get
ready for the colorful cast of
characters with extreme personalities
all have to somehow work together to
make it a success but there's apparently
a phantom they think it's more of a
legend whenever little things go wrong
around the theater but tonight the
premiere even more things are going
wrong and everyone's afraid it's gonna
sabotage the big night so it's up to our
crew of silly troublemakers to try and
figure out who the Phantom is and how to
stop it on the one hand I kind of like
this idea there's something about movie
theaters that always feel little
mysterious and even kind of magical I
can't explain it people who work there
often have a lot of interesting stories
and they usually have a love for film as
well and this movie for as over-the-top
as it is seems to capture that my
favorite thing believe it or not is
Mickey Rooney as an old guy who thinks
he works there at first he just seems
like a crazy old kook who won't go away
but the more you listen to him the more
you realize how totally sucked in and
intrigued he is by films he constantly
talks about how magical they are and how
they take you to distant lands it's so
corny and so cheesy but the way he says
a lot this dialogue I do find myself
kind of enjoying it there's a legit
passion to his performance and maybe
some of that does come from the fact
that it is Mickey Rooney playing if he
was one of the biggest stars in the
world and he does have all this history
nothing about his performance ever feels
phoned in it really seems like he just
gets teleported somewhere incredible
whenever he talks about film to a point
where he even stops people from seeing
bad movies and won't let them in and
directs them to better one
it's so ridiculous but it's so not even
innocent you kind of gotta love it
that's probably the best way to describe
this film to not even innocent it's one
of those movies where you pick up right
away what kind of audience they're
trying to hit it's for little kids and
they act big for little kids and they go
really goofy for little kids and they
make up these weird lines for little
kids and dad for a little kids movie
that has to entirely take place in a
movie theater which isn't exactly the
most exciting place for a kids movie I
do get why it's this over-the-top so is
there anything in it for grown-ups no is
there anything in it for older kids no
will it last the test of time it already
isn't but I can't really get angry at it
for doing exactly what it's doing being
a kids film about a movie theater with a
creepy little phantom there's always a
feeling that it's trying with the
creativity I mean everything that the
phantom sabotage is somehow ties into a
movie like in a tornado movie he turns
the air up in a movie about water he
turns on the sprinklers and so forth the
climax even centers around him putting
this giant Godzilla balloon inside a
theater and one of the kids has to grab
a sword prop from a movie called Merlin
on Mars and go after it like a knight
attacking a dragon it's so childlike
you're ridiculous it's kind of adorable
so do I recommend it only to little kids
I think they're the only ones they'll
really get into it and hey it's kind of
teaching him that movies are really cool
and they can really spark a lot of
magical things and that's a good thing
to teach kids I say for everyone else
it's a definite pass but it's an
understandable pass it's childish it's
silly but that's just what some kids
movies are supposed to be
you
[Music]